prior to like Spotify and all this other
stuff and like YouTube was like that
platform that everybody used to go out
there and really like show what they had
and I think like when I was growing up
like having an Asian guy singing like
R&B music was not a thing like people
did not expect that so you know just to
go back to Jeremy passion when he was he
was doing it I just had to jump on that
[ __ ] wave dude and I always try to be
a comic too but I was like yo man making
people laugh does not get me vagina
whatsoever it would always be a
situation where like if let's say we're
at I was at a bar or something and this
is like in my 20s like oh you should
meet my friend David Mann he makes he's
really really funny it's like cool and
it goes like oh you're really funny cool
but then they would leave with some
other guy okay you know what I need to
start doing music that's what I'm gonna
do because music is amazing hell yeah I
remember um watching your skits cuz I
was definitely I was introduced to you
with the UCLA girl yeah video the rat
that you had about her and then I think
slowly on your channel you started to
promote that you had your music channel
yeah I'm actually started with the music
channel first before my comedy I didn't
know but yeah and so like because you
like cross-reference those channels
together yeah um I clicked on one of
your videos and you started singing I
was like oh my god dude this fool can
sing I wanted to be a musician first so
prior prior to by David so comedy
channel I actually had a music channel
before that that I deleted so my type of
personality and maybe I didn't share
this story before but I deleted it and
you know at the time I can't remember
the exact subscribers subscriber count
that I had on it but it was pretty high
for the time and yeah whatever I might
have said like a random number before
just to give something you know give
something for people to bite on yeah but
let's say it was like I don't know like
a hundred thousand followers during that
time it was a lot and this is during my
music channel days I deleted all those
videos so in the same fashion that I had
what like genius brain when I when I
when I rebranded my channel from Davis
Davis okami to genius brain I did the
same thing for my music to going in the
comedy and the reason why I did that was
because I when I was trying to be a
comic there was it there was a big issue
that I had
and it's a lot of issues that I think
young people have when I was young and
the biggest problem that that that is is
having too many options and I wanted to
do everything and anything and it's
still a problem that I had to till this
day it's like when you want to do
everything and anything the problem with
that is that you'll never be able to
master a single craft really well if you
master craft it's gonna be a constant
thing that's going on but you won't be
able to get to a certain level if you
keep splitting up your time with six or
seven different things so when I started
doing music I started doing music and
comedy around the same time but I was
way more into music than it was comedy
and so I had to make a choice I was like
okay so what are you going to be are you
going to be a comic or you going to be a
musician and at during this time I was
putting more time in the music but I
fell in love with comedy so I had to
make a choice so I could keep this
acoustic soul or whatever but I felt
that because I had this it was it was
gonna hold me back so I did a very tough
thing at the time I deleted that channel
I completely deleted it
not like not just hide it private it no
I don't I don't even know if YouTube had
that option at that time or maybe I was
just dumb and I didn't know he's deleted
the whole [ __ ] channel but I actually
deleted my music channel that had maybe
like a hundred thousand followers and
whatever that number was it was a big
big accomplishment and I was booking
shows through that like San Francisco
and I was doing that show collaboration
before I even became a bigger youtuber
because I was so focused on music and so
when I left that I deleted it I said you
know what there's no turning back delete
that channel we want to start the comedy
1 and I started my comedy when David saw
comedy after I deleted that channel so
then how did you fall in love with
comedy because like I was we were so
into music yeah but I was always doing
comedy like I started to I you know I
had fake IDs I would hit up these comedy
clubs and because I was I was this sick
I was like 6 foot 1 when I was 3 years
old so you know I mean and I still don't
have facial hair but I I'm I'm more
curious about how your fake ID look like
it just it looked like a regular
California license ID I know what was it
with your picture on there yeah look old
I see like I've looked like legit had
the same face as I was like
at 16 dammit I was hoping that it was a
picture that looked completely different
from here no it was my face and you know
like tooth like some of these clubs
don't give a [ __ ] dude you know so um I
will get into these comedy clubs and
then um long story short I just started
falling in love with comedy more and to
be honest with you was it was mainly
because I think I was just a better
comedian than I was a musician like I
never really loved music as much as I
loved making people laugh and the reason
why was because like even right now and
it goes back to me understanding um just
like music history I know nothing about
it like you know we were struggling to
say say who Freddie Mercury was yeah you
know somebody who's like highly iconic
in in music in general and I don't know
these people I don't know all this
different music even if you asked like
hip-hop artists right you asked them
about certain musicians that made big
waves even if it's outside of their
genre they'll know what what we're what
they're talking about or whoever
whatever or whatever that person is
talking about if they're having a
conversation with somebody about music
and that's because it's their job I
didn't have that same passion for music
I I did not and so for me I had to
understand okay are you going to waste
your time on something that's just a
hobby just because you're using it just
because it gives you attention or are
you gonna put your time into something
that makes you really happy right right
and comedy made me happy comedy was away
from me since I was a little kid I was a
goofball yeah right I didn't know the
craft about it I didn't go to like UCB
or anything else like that I just had
real world world experience I just went
up on stage and I saw what happened yeah
so comedy was something that just always
rewarded me with something that was more
than just like recognition like the the
ability to make somebody laugh about
something you're not supposed to laugh
about was a task that I really enjoyed
and it started off with me right so when
like I think we mentioned this before
and on the podcast that we did I was a
fat kid still a bigger guy now but as a
fat kid a lot of kids would make fun of
you um whether it was because of my
glasses the way I looked the way I
behaved or well it didn't really matter
but with comedy you're allowed to take
those negative attributes and flip it
and make it into something funny so I
would do that by making fun of myself
first before somebody else could yeah
and for me laughter and comedy was so
healing
yeah which made me want to pursue it and
I think like that's why I went into the
stander brah yeah so stand up was like
the big thing for me because being able
to grab a mic go up on stage make people
laugh and people said like you do like
you just you know yeah crack me the [ __ ]
up and changed my perspective how was
how was your first your very first
performance like my very first
performance was actually this church
like right around the corner from my
place it was right across this park that
we use go but there was a church that
opened up in like this warehouse area
and they did an open mic comedy night
and I just remember I just walked in
there and I just did a terrible terrible
set it was so [ __ ] bad like bad
because no one laughed he left that was
not funny
I was not funny I see you know just
because because people don't understand
like just because you're our funny
person doesn't mean you could do
stand-up comedy I have a friend back in
Sacramento that wanted to do stand-up
too and he did stand-up and mind you if
we're in a conversation let's say like
me and you like let's say you're
obviously I'm me and you're him right he
could make me laugh and go into tears
yeah but if you put him onstage with the
mic cuz he thought that the the
conversations that we were having that
he could turn into stand-up but he
couldn't because it takes skill it takes
storytelling it takes nuance takes
practice is it's it's it's a really
difficult craft yeah I'm not saying I'm
an amazing stand-up comic but you know
I've I can do it decently yeah you know
I I obviously haven't practiced it in
years but this guy he didn't really
understand how difficult stand-up was
and so he went up on stage and he bought
and this is him like later on this is I
after like six years I've been doing
stand-up he started doing stand-up - and
he would just go up on stage and [ __ ]
crickets because he would try to tell
these stories on stage to a group of
strangers but the reason why they were
funny to us is because the people that
he would talk about in those stories we
knew who they were so there was already
a background to it so he would never
setup his jokes and we would try to get
him to understand that and he just kept
bombing over all oh that sounds like a
nightmare
it is it's nerve-wracking it's hard
stand-up is a very difficult craft
that's why when I watch people like
Bobby Lee he's been doing it for years
the guy's a master is crap yeah
do you know um obviously I mean I'm
still still a fan of you David but like
when I was a super fan like way back
because I didn't know much about you I
tried so hard to try to find videos of
you doing your stand-up and like I was
just trying to figure out there's a few
now I know there is a few like I managed
to find a few and I was one of those
people that was so down and ready to
[ __ ] buy a ticket and watch you do
stand-up yeah I am when I was doing
stand-up pretty actively so it was only
when I first started like the first two
years and so I would go like the
Icehouse Pasadena and I would like do
material but then I slowly started to
find out that a lot of these a lot of
these college shows were different than
doing a stand-up at a at an actual
comedy club
so comedy clubs they were a lot more
open yeah you could say what I'm talking
about you go to comedy clubs depending
on which one you go to and who goes up
it will say some wild [ __ ] and nobody
really gets that offended you know aside
from saying very like racially offensive
things depending on who that person is
right so I'm like let's say if a white
dudes up their knees thrashing on black
people as a joke probably not gonna go
over really well right right or if a
dude is trashing on women without any
nuance and not without any background to
it then obviously it's gonna go bad but
other than that is pretty open it was a
it was like a safe space you get to go
up there go to a comedy club test your
material out if it fails go back to the
drawing board either you rewrite that
joke you say if you still believe in the
joke you either rewrite it or you trash
it and move on yeah yeah College shows
were a little different it was more it
wasn't a lot of the stuff that would
kill in the comedy club that I would use
mm-hmm I would try to do it at College
shows if people get either a Fender or
they feel weird about it oh this is a
very different space so for me before
though I would walk up on stage I would
like people to the blinds and the
curtains and I would look take a look at
everybody out there yeah like I would
look I'm like what's the age group yeah
how many women are in there how many
dudes and I would kind of base it off
that type of stuff just because like I
felt like the college crowd was a little
more sensitive they wouldn't listen to
the comedy they would just listen for
trigger words and get mad mm-hmm and I
hated that [ __ ] because it's like dude
you got to listen to the content first
like don't you
get angry just to be angry at this
program right so like I mean I plan to
do stand-up again starting actually next
year I would love to go and see you I
want to support you let me buy the
ticket yeah so we're gonna like I'm
definitely gonna do stand-up next year
for sure my people don't know like in
this phone and in my computer I have
literally like hundreds of pages of
stand-up I constantly write all the time
it's just something I did I've done
since I was 16
yeah yeah whenever I find something
funny I write it down oh my gosh so then
like prior to you actually performing up
on stage how like I guess how long do
you practice like do you do your whole
set
it depends for me because I had such
short sets when I first started out and
I was an absolute nobody I rarely ever
got like past 15 minutes to do a set
yeah um I didn't prep much I have a lot
of hitters and I would do a lot of crowd
work the longest show that I did was out
in Minnesota I did an hour set whoa yeah
I did an hour set that was super barge
over there so they were there to witness
my first hour set down yeah I did a full
[ __ ] hour and I don't remember
anything that I said cuz it was such a
last-minute show I didn't I didn't get
the prep for it very well and so they
surprised he was like oh surprise we
booked you for an hour no I
it wasn't confirmed that I was gonna do
the show and it didn't seem like he was
gonna get booked so I didn't prep for it
oh I sound like a [ __ ] it's not gonna
happen so and then when it got booked
booked there was like two weeks out and
I was busy doing other things that I
didn't really get to prepare but the
good thing is because I've done stand-up
for so long I still had a lot of old
sets in my head yeah and so I had a
tweak it to make it funny I mean some of
the stuff didn't do as well but I mean
Bart Joe said I killed it I don't know
if they're being nice but I remember
what pretty why I think people were
laughing I mean I did an hour and then
people were cracking up so hopefully
that means I did well yeah but who knows
like you know comedy - it's one of those
things that I felt like after a while
started to die out for me um not because
I don't like stand-up comedy anymore it
was because I just was tapped out like
it didn't bring the same joy Oh sting
because all I ever wanted to do was be a
stand-up comic originally that's it yeah
and then um after a while it was just
like ah there's other ways to make
people laugh and that's when YouTube
popped up you know YouTube was I was
like oh I could
people left doing sketches and writing
and there's other ways to express my
humor and get people to feel that same
way through a different Avenue and that
was through writing sketches you know
doing these comedy vlogs so you know
quote-unquote vlogs and doing that type
of [ __ ] so you've you've changed a lot
that's have changed quite it happens and
people people don't understand like
people oh how do you how do you have
your life figured out I don't have my
[ __ ] life I don't think anyone does
nobody does and that's what happens a
lot of people they look at somebody else
and they say well how do I get to be
that person because they have everything
figured out they don't nobody [ __ ]
has [ __ ] figured out yeah I don't I
don't know what I'm doing at all out of
our group out of the main people I'm
probably the one that has zero I mean I
have a loose direction but I'm just I
don't even know how my life is right now
I don't even know how I'm living you
know it's and that's how life's supposed
to be though